[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec pauline
déroulède bonjour merci de partager ce
moment avec nous vous êtes assistante
réalisateur est professeur de tennis
lorsque votre vie bascule un samedi
d'octobre 2010 8 vous avez alors 27 ans
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
alors que vous vous trouvez sur votre
scooter à l'arrêt sur un trottoir vous
est amputé de la jambe gauche
vous allez passer plusieurs mois à
l'hôpital subir de nombreuses opérations
une très longue rééducation
près de deux ans et demi plus tard vous
imposer comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris en 2024
que de chemin parcouru quel regard est
ce que vous portez sur ces deux
dernières années bonjour sa fait bonjour
à tous c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup
de chemin parcouru j'ai dû me relever
très vite
de toute façon je me suis je me suis pas
laissé le choix puisque quelques heures
après mon accident j'ai dit à ma famille
à mes proches que je voulais faire les
jeux paralympiques en 2024 puisque
j'avais en tête qu'on allait accueillir
ces grands événements dans notre pays
dans ma ville donc voilà c'est vrai que
le sport m'a toujours sauver déjà dans
ma vie d'avant quand j'étais assistante
real je faisais beaucoup de sport
beaucoup de tennis et il m'a sauvé à
nouveau au pire moment de ma vie puisque
voilà j'ai eu cet objectif en tête et et
j'ai essayé de remonter la pente et la
fédération française de tennis m'a fait
confiance et aujourd'hui j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin et je suis
je suis ravi de ce chemin donc c'est
vrai que il ya des moments où où on
réfléchit à tout ce qui s'est passé et
voilà je me dis que je suis privilégié
d'être en vie et
je vois là je suis plutôt plutôt fier du
chemin parcouru en tout cas mais avant
d'en arriver là il va vous falloir mener
un long combat pour vous réapproprier
votre corps pour réapprendre à vivre
avec ce nouveau corps avec cette
prothèse aussi là aussi c'est votre
mental de sportifs qui a été déterminant
oui c'est vrai que d'avoir fait beaucoup
de sport avant cet accident
samassa à cultiver chez moi un état
d'esprit de compétition je pense j'ai
mais j'avais déjà le goût de l'effort
j'avais déjà le goût de la compétition
donc je pense que ça m'a vraiment servi
lors de ce drame puisque j'ai dû me
battre j'ai dû survivre
les premières semaines et voilà je pense
que c'était un esprit m'a jamais quitté
et aussi il ya quelque chose d'important
c'est que j'ai eu la chance je dis bien
la chance d'atterrir à l'hôpital
militaire de percy et quand je suis
rentrée notamment en phase de
rééducation
j'étais entouré de combattants qui
revenait d'opérations extérieures et il
y avait vraiment cet état d'esprit de
guerrier et voilà ça m'a habité ils
m'ont beaucoup inspiré ces gens là j'ai
fait en contre extraordinaire et les moi
même
à l'époque quand j'étais dans cet
hôpital je me considérais comme un petit
soldat modestement pour essayer de
donner de la force et d'aller toujours
plus loin
finalement après l'accident on imagine
quel regard des autres aussi qui change
sur soi comment est ce que on la fronde
comment est ce que vous l'avez affronter
c'est vrai que le regard des gens sur le
handicap en général il est difficile à
accepter
d'autant plus quand il est visible et
moi voilà une prothèse ça se voit c'est
visuellement on peut pas la cacher sauf
quand on est en pantalon éventuellement
et je suis sorti de rééducation voilà
huit mois plus tard après une
hospitalisation et c'était l'été est en
fait je n'ai à nouveau pas eu le choix
puisque je n'allais pas me mettre en
pantalon avec des grosses chaleurs et je
me suis pas laissé le choix j'ai
affronté ce regard qui était difficile à
supporter au début mai mais toujours
bien entouré
j'ai essayé de ne pas me défiler parce
que je pense que c'était important de
voies l'a26 confronté très tôt pour ne
pas avoir à le faire plus tard après il
ya encore des moments où c'est difficile
je prends toujours l'exemple des enfants
moi je trouve ça assez sympa quand des
enfants évidemment montrent du doigt on
va pas leur en vouloir ma prothèse
il ya vraiment un côté des étoiles dans
leurs yeux et moi je retiens cette image
d'un petit garçon qui avait montré ma
prothèse en disant regarde c'est une
forme de robot une jambe de super-héros
maman et voilà et donc quand il ya un
regard un peu déplacé et je comprends
c'est normal de regarder une prothèse
moi même je l'aurais fait avant ben je
repense à cette phrase et me dit que
j'ai une jambe de super héros et ça
m'aide à tenir debout
vous participez au programme de la
relève en mars 2010 9,5 mois je crois
après votre accident là relève c'est ce
programme qui est mise en place par le
comité olympique en vue des jeux
paralympiques de 2024 pour dénicher des
athlètes à haut potentiel à ce moment là
qu est ce que vous vous dites qu'est ce
qui vous motive vraiment à concourir
et bien c'est vrai que là relève c'est
un programme de détection qui m'a permis
de réaliser mon objectif de commencer à
le réaliser en tout cas puisque c'était
un endroit une journée où il y avait
toutes les fédérations de tous les
sports puisque quelques mois auparavant
quand j'ai décidé de vouloir à
participer au jeu a paris je ne savais
pas encore dans quelle discipline
j'avais en tête évidemment le tennis
puisque c'est à ça a toujours été mon
sport j'en faisais beaucoup j'avais une
autre casquette de voilà un second
métier qui avait celui de donner des
cours à des enfants donc bien sûr
j'avais pensé au tennis mais mais le
tennis je savais que ça se pratiquait en
fauteuil handisport et j'ai pas honte de
le dire mais j'avais beaucoup
d'appréhension à beaucoup d'à priori sur
l'image du fauteuil roulant et du coup
je vois là je suis lassé de journée en
me disant je vais faire du triathlon
j'aime être au triathlon je vais aller
aux jeux de paris pour faire du
triathlon et et cette journée m'a
permise de faire des rencontres à
nouveau notamment de la salle de la
fédération française de tennis qui m'a
vendu du rêve qui m'a vendu un beau
projet m'a dit que j'avais des chances
d'aller loin et
et ils m'ont convaincu donc cette
journée elle a vraiment permis
elle m'a vraiment permis de voir ça a
été le point de départ de tous et à
l'issue de la journée j'ai fait les
rencontres qu'il fallait j'ai notamment
rencontré stéphane houdet qui a été
champion olympique champion du monde
numéro un français qui qui lui
finalement c'est un peu comme un grand
frère maintenance et on est très proche
on a même handicapé dans ce sud et
hermine nantes
et en effet ça a été une rencontre
déterminante parce que voilà moi je
j'avais peur du fauteuil roulant j'avais
la chance encore une fois de pouvoir
être de goût grâce une prothèse et
finalement j'ai toujours voulu
revendiquer ce cette fierté là peut-être
et il m'a dit le phrase simple quand
j'ai rencontré à roland garros on avait
invité et et m'a dit tu sais pauline moi
j'arrive debout je fais mon match de
tennis je gagne mon match de tennis et
je repars debout et c'est tout bête mais
samassa m'a fait comprendre que le fait
de jouer au tennis en fauteuil ça ne
dispenserait pas pour autant de pouvoir
marcher dans la vraie vie donc voilà
donc grâce à lui j'ai fait mon chemin
j'ai rencontré ensuite ma coach aurélie
soma riba qui m'a fait confiance et et
l'aventuré a commencé il ya maintenant
un an et demi et qu'est ce qu'il
représente
à ce moment-là à vendre 7 avant cette
rencontre ce fauteuil roulant quelques a
priori est ce que vous vous en avez
c'est vrai que le fauteuil roulant
cesser voilà moi j'avais beaucoup d'à
priori parce que ça faisait trop
handicapé
je pensais que le tennis fauteuil
n'allait pas être assez physique pour
moi est en fait voilà je me rendais pas
compte j'avais jamais
vue du handisport parce que
malheureusement c'est encore peu manif
médiatisé je le déplore d'ailleurs et
c'est seulement voilà avec dans des
discussions qu'on m'a vendu un beau
projet et voilà que je me suis dit voilà
c'est vrai que le tennis c'est que c'est
mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait c'est le fait d'essayer
qui m'a convaincu parce que je me suis
rendu compte que c'est ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi parce que
c'est une nouvelle technique aussi à
apprendre
oui il ya évidemment une technique de
déplacement totalement différent de
lorsqu'on est debout puisque nos jambes
c'est notre fauteuil c'est les rounds
fauteuil donc il faut apprendre à manier
le fauteuil et moi j'ai quand même un
gros handicap
en plus c'est que je ne suis pas en
fauteuil dans la vraie vie donc il faut
vraiment que je travaille ce déplacement
en fauteuil pour m'habituer à voile à me
déplacer correctement rapidement ce qui
n'est pas ce qui est peut-être moins le
cas de d'autres joueuses qui ont un
handicap qui sont paraplégiques et qui
du coup sont dans le quotidien en
fauteuil roulant donc après moi j'ai un
avantage c'est que mon handicap n'est
pas lourd je n'ai qu'une seule jambe en
moins mais j'ai mes ados et ça me permet
physiquement de tenir le coup donc voilà
donc j'ai énormément travaillé ce
déplacement en fauteuil je vais
travailler encore aujourd'hui et je te
contentes du résultat parce que on
partait de zéro
parce que le fauteuil roulant
aujourd'hui au quotidien vous vous le
refusez c'est votre outil de travail
finalement aujourd'hui exactement c'est
mon outil de travail
c'est vraiment mon outil de travail au
même titre que ma raquette de tennis
je ne suis jamais en fauteuil je ne suis
jamais en fauteuil
évidemment le soir j'enlève ma prothèse
pour pour aller me coucher ça les gens
n'ont sans doute pas mais c'est vrai que
c'est d'ailleurs une des questions que
j'avais posé à l'hôpital où j'étais
étonné de savoir créer enlever sa
prothèse mais finalement quand j'en ai
porté une j'ai compris que c'était
plutôt confortable de l'enlever le soir
parce que c'est c'est comme si on était
compressé en permanence dans une
chaussure donc on est on est content de
l'enlever mais voilà quand j'ai pu me
protège me déplace à la cause à
cloche-pied je me laisse pas le choix
encore une fois aujourd'hui vous mener
une vie de sportive de haut niveau vous
dit que c'était un rêve qu'a permis
votre accident c'est tout le paradoxe
oui je dis que c'est un peu l'ironie de
mon sort parce que quand j'étais petit
c'était un rêve de devenir sportif de
haut niveau à deux reprises j'ai failli
suivre une filière sport études et je
n'ai pas fait j'avais d'ailleurs aucun
regret puisque dans la vie d'avant tant
qu'assistante real dans le domaine
audiovisuel j'étais très épanouie donc
je suis content de l'avoir vécu ces
choses là mais mais voilà j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec une jambe en moins
donc c'est paradoxal comme vous dites
donc j'aime ma vie mais bien sûr que si
demain on me rendais ma jambe je les
reprendrai mais la question ne se pose
pas donc je prends ce qu'il ya à prendre
et j'essaye toujours de transformer ce
drame
en quelque chose d'autre et finalement
le chemin que j'ai choisis à travers le
sport à travers un objectif
paralympiques
je pense que c'était le meilleur chemin
pour moi comment est ce que vous vivez
vous vivez cette pandémie parce que
comme l'ensemble des sports le
handisport a lui aussi été durement
touché par la crise comment est ce que
vous avez vécu notamment le premier
confinement ça a été une période très
difficile
je dois dire que le premier confinement
l'année dernière a été très difficile à
vivre pour tout le monde et moi je les
mal vécu sur le plan personnel parce que
ça m'a rappelé le l'hôpital en fait ça
m'a rappelé ce temps qu'ils étaient à
l'arrêt ou je devais subir et gt line
active
je ne pouvais pas la bouger comme je
voulais moi je suis quelqu'un qui est
dans l'action qu'ils aiment faire du
sport qui est ça que c'était très
compliqué à gérer et c'était très proche
de la période finalement dans laquelle
j'étais sorti de l'hôpital et ça m'a
rappelé ce temps à l'arrêt mais là la
chose que je me disais pour essayer de
remonter
pendant tout le premier confinement
c'est que j'avais de la chance de ne pas
être à l'hôpital pendant cette crise qui
traverse le pays
parce que je sais ce que c'est d'être
l'hôpital notamment les week-ends où le
personnel était réduit où il n'y a pas
de visite et voilà j'ai pensé à tous ces
gens qui va qui était hospitalisée et
qui n'avait pas de visite qui avait le
vide
voilà en fait il faut toujours
relativiser c'est un peu c'est un peu le
cas quand des personnes ont vécu un
accident de vie il ya des voilà il ya
des petits problèmes des plus gros
problèmes
et voilà mais bien sûr qu'il ya des
moments d'arn le confinement en a été un
pour moi mais on se relève vous restez
avec nous pauline des relais dont fait
une courte pause on se retrouve juste
après a tout de suite
[Musique]
elle de retour dans la grande interview
que nous sommes nous en compagnie de
pauline déroulède espoir français pour
les jeux paralympiques de paris 2024
pauline vous êtes aujourd'hui une
sportive de haut niveau c'est un
changement de vie radical
en effet j'ai radicalement changer de
vie puisque je me lève le matin pour
aller faire le sport que j'aime le plus
au monde le tennis donc c'est plutôt
sympa je je je vois là je me sens
privilégié de cette nouvelle vie je
n'aurais pas pu mieux choisir donc
donc voilà je vais évidemment que j'ai
des moments nostalgie où je repense à
avant et encore une fois j'étais très
épanouie dans cette ville à mai mais
voilà cela vivier maintenant me convient
et je pense que c'est une manière
une bonne manière d'avancer et de
surmonter le handicap aussi au quotidien
et alors comment est ce que vous vous
entraînez à quoi ressemble une journée
type de pauline déroulède alors une
journée type de pauline dérouler les
traits chercher parce que parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses dans la vie aussi à
côté du sport voilà moi je m'entraîne
quatre heures par jour minimum avec de
tennis et avec de la préparation
physique en plus et à la fin de journée
vers 17 heures il ya une nouvelle
journée qui commence ou à là où je fais
plutôt des des rendez vous plus
politique puisque j'ai un autre combat
dans ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière
voilà donc ces jeux j'ai deux journées
en une et ça me convient voilà moi je
les combats qui me tiennent à coeur les
objectifs que je me fie que j'essaie de
les remplir à fond et
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire en tout
cas et au plan sportif à quoi ressemble
une séance d'entraînement alors tennis
fauteuil on sollicite évidemment
beaucoup le haut du corps vous imaginez
bien donc c'est vrai comme moi j'avais
déjà voilà une bonne préparation
physique parce que je faisais beaucoup
de crossfit avant mon accident donc il a
fallu renforcer tous les os du corps
donc moi je jeu sur le terrain je
évidemment je fais beaucoup de
répétitions avec la raquette voilà deux
coups de tactique mais aussi beaucoup de
déplacements en fauteuil parce que comme
je vous le disais moi c'est vraiment le
point sur le web sur lequel je dois
travailler peut-être plus que les autres
et en préparation physique on va faire
beaucoup de musculation de renforcement
du 3 dobbin atra domina le pardon donc
voilà c'est intense et il ya beaucoup de
volume beaucoup de volume d'entraînement
donc on est suivi dans le centre où je
m'entraîne au comité des yvelines par
évidemment des ostéo des kinés qui
surveille qui font nous fait faire de la
prévention pour éviter le risque de
blessure ça fait deux ans que vous y
êtes mise espoir féminin c'est quand
même pas courant
comme bart cours comme réussite c'est
assez rapide en tout cas ça nous semble
rapide
oui je sais pas oui peut-être peut-être
que c'est rapide je me rends pas bien
compte en fait j'ai pas vraiment de
recul sur sur sur sa mémé mais oui moi
c'est vrai que j'ai un leitmotiv surtout
depuis l'accident qui est de dire plus
le times et
voilà j'ai plus le temps plus de temps à
perdre en tout cas donc évidemment il
faut prendre le temps parfois pour
certaines choses mais mais d'en avoir
cet état d'esprit de foncer et d'aller
vite vite et bien
donc espoir féminin je ne sais pas c'est
pas moi qui le dit mais en tout cas moi
je m'investis beaucoup je m'entraîne
sérieusement pour remplir les objectifs
qu'il faut et avant les jeux il y aura
évidemment d'autres échéances
donc je vais chez en avance qu'elle
déchire aux quelles sont les étapes
cruciales avant 2024 avant 2024
déjà il ya quelque chose que qui avait
bien d'être rempli c'est que je devais
être sélectionné en équipe de france
donc donc c'est le cas donc je vois là
c'est une première victoire
petite victoire malgré en plus cela la
crise sanitaire qui nous empêche pour le
moment de de faire de la compétition
notamment à l'international
mais ça va reprendre et évidemment les
autres étapes avant les jeux c'est de
voile à faire des championnats du monde
en équipe de france
peut-être je l'espère prochainement
joints de gagner les championnats de
france parce que je pense que c'est un
titre important et et voilà il faut être
remontée dans le classement mondial
puisque pourrait qualifier pour les jeux
il faut faire partie du top 30
ce qui est réalisable ce qui est plus
compliqué pour autant c'est d'être
qualifié pour les grands chelems
néamoins jeu j'ai en tête un autre rêve
de petite fille dans le rêve de petite
fille c'est de participer à roland
garros puisqu'il s'agit d'un grand
chelem un grand chelem par non et en
tennis fauteuil il ya seulement un
tableau de huit joueurs donc c'est très
très restreint mais comme il s'agit d'un
tournoi français la fédération française
de tennis chaque année donne une wild
card à la numéro un française
donc l'objectif prochain c'est d'être
numéro un française pour pour faire
roland garros et on vous le souhaite en
parallèle de votre carrière de sportif
vous menez donc aujourd'hui un autre
combat celui ci pour la prévention
routière notamment pour que les
personnes âgées soient contrôlés une
fois un certain âge un temps si elles
veulent continuer à prendre le volant
c'est un engagement presque viscéral
qu'est ce que vous demandez précisément
alors moi c'est vrai que les
circonstances de mon accident ont fait
que ça a été médiatisé ça a relancé ce
débat là qui ne date pas d'hier à savoir
les seniors au volant puisque le
conducteur qui m'a fauché qui a perdu le
contrôle de son véhicule et est âgé de
plus de 90 ans
et voilà et moi je me suis emparé de ce
combat quelques mois après mon accident
je parce que je pense que c'est
important d'incarner en tant que victime
mais même si j'aime pas ce titre là
voilà je pense que j'avais la force de
le faire pour toutes les victimes
oubliées d' accidents de la route en
général et je me suis dit qu'en france
c'était délirant ahurissant qui n'existe
rien autour du permis de conduire et
qu'on ait un permis de conduire de
manière illimitée alors qu'on accorde
énormément d'attention d'importance à
sur la sécurité routière l'alcool au
volant le portable au volant mais on ne
commence pas par la base l'attitude
d'une personne à conduire et c'est vrai
que on parle souvent des personnes âgées
au volant bien sûr c'est c'est une
catégorie de personnes qui peut être
dangereux au volant
à tous mais voilà moi depuis je
travaille avec la sécurité routière
plusieurs ministre qui me soutiennent et
qui m'accompagnent dans ce projet de loi
parce qu'il s'agit d'un projet de loi
qui vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors c'est que ces
contrôles ont les frais d'une manière
une fréquence qui évoluerait selon l'âge
évidemment mais il n'est pas question de
stigmatiser une partie de la population
parce que on a parlé en parlant avec des
médecins on s'est aperçu qu'il ya aussi
des gens qui ne sont pas forcément âgées
mais qui ont des pathologies des
maladies dégénératives moi qui voit
moins bien
donc voilà il ya plein de petits
facteurs pas seulement l'âge qui
altèrent la conduite et on est un des
rares pays en europe avec l'allemagne à
ne rien faire donc j'ai dans tous les
autres pays il ya une loi qui existe
on doit passer des tests à partir d'un
certain âge donc effectivement c'est un
long combat parce qu'il faut convaincre
du monde
moi je reçois énormément de témoignages
de deux vies brisées de deux accidents
de vie qui me pousse qui donne la force
de continuer ce combat là j'ai également
aussi demandé et j'ai obtenu cet échange
avec le conducteur qui m'a fauché pour
moi c'était important de le rencontrer
avec le co vie dont on a pu échanger en
visio mais le résultat était le même
c'était très intéressant pour moi et ça
a été essentielle il ya clairement eu un
avant et un après sur le plan personnel
déjà je pense que c'était une étape dans
ma reconstruction et je ne voyais pas
défendre ce combat-là de sécurité
routière sans avoir eu une discussion
avec cet homme là et qu'est ce qui lie
mali des phrases oncle est évidemment
vous imaginez bien que c'est quelqu'un
qui est meurtri il n'y a pas que sa vie
à lui qui est brisée à celle de tout son
entourage
et c'est ce que je me suis dit en
sortant de cet échange c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de vies abîmé pour que pour
quelque chose qui aurait pu être évitée
et voilà c'est une personne qui qui est
bien élevé qui a toujours tout respecté
dans sa vie qui fait qu'ils prenaient
plus la voiture que pour des petits
trajets quand il m'a fauché il allait
acheter son pain et qui savait qu'il
n'était plus capable de conduire
il le savait et il avait d'ailleurs pris
la décision d'arrêter de conduire un
mois après l'accident
et quand je lui ai dit ce qu'ils
pensaient de voilà de ce projet c'est
important pour moi d'avoir son avis il
m'a dit moi s'il y avait une loi je leur
ai respectées et ça je pense que c'est
très important parce qu'alors qu'il est
on confie la responsabilité de faire
arrêter de quelqu'un de conduire aux
proches à la famille et c'est très
culpabilisant et ça devrait pas être aux
proches de d'avoir ce rôle
c'est ce que je me tue à dire à l'état
puisque on a un contrôle technique de
son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
une loi sur ce sujet là et comment
avancent les échanges avec toutes ces
rencontres que vous faites vous dites
que vous faites partie de comités
interministériels vous discuté de ce
projet de loi depuis un certain temps
maintenant est ce que est ce qu'il va
voir le jour
qu'est ce qui freine aujourd'hui écoutés
oui ça en avance prudemment mais
sûrement
mais je suis en lien permanent avec
effectivement la déléguée
interministérielle
ce qui bloque aujourd'hui c'est les
solutions alternatives de mobilité en
fait on c'est facile pour nous de faire
des tests
puisqu'on a les auto écoles on a des
médecins qui sont des acteurs essentiels
dans ce projet mais le plus gros
chantier c'est de proposer proposer
d'autres solutions pour se déplacer
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens qui ne
serait plus capable de conduire et
notamment les campagnes dans l'est dans
les villages les villes excentré il faut
proposer des solutions de navettes et ça
sur le plan logistique c'est très
compliqué c'est pas un faisable mais sa
demande d un certain budget ça demande
une certaine logistique sur plan
national donc on y travaille c'est long
mais là prochainement je vais faire
partie d'un d'un colloque avec plusieurs
représentants de la sécurité routière
avec des à des avocats spécialisés dans
le dommage corporel des médecins la
sécurité routière a tenu à vraiment
faire une équipe sur ce projet de loi et
il y aura une conférence nationale qui
se tiendra prochainement avant l'été sur
le sujet sur la mobilité en général les
seniors au volant et ce projet de test
d'aptitude à la conduite
vous semblez écouter aujourd'hui mais
très concrètement qui vous soutient dans
cette proposition de projet de loi
au plan politique notamment écoutez je
peux vous dire que il ya une vraie
nouvelle attention de la part du
gouvernement moi ça fait deux ans que
j'ai eu cet accident
ça fait un an et demi que j'ai commencé
à amener ce combat est depuis quelques
mois
malgré encore une fois le contexte
sanitaire le gouvernement voit la porte
une nouvelle attention j'ai reçu le
soutien d' emmanuel macron de jean
castex
voilà des personnalités politiques assez
bien placé et je vois là moi je suis en
train de former une vraie équipe autour
de moi deux ministres notamment la
ministre des solidarités sophie cluzel
qui elle à travers sa fonction porté sur
les solutions pour le handicap à des
solutions de transport adapté qui
pourrait être déployé sur tout le
territoire est également ministre des
transports jean mercier djebbari qui
comme son nom l'indiqué
s'occupe des transports donc voila moi
je m'entoure des bonnes personnes parce
que je pense que ce n'est pas un défi
personnel c'est pas ça ne concerne pas
que moi moi c'est trop tard j'ai envie
de dire mais je pense que c'est
important de le faire pour les autres
notre population est vieillissante on
voit là on est obligés de faire quelque
chose sur le permis de conduire de
d'encadrer ce permis de conduire en
france et l'équipe se monte le
gouvernement me soutient je sens une
vraie un vrai support on va dire delà de
leur part donc j'ai bon espoir que que
ça passe mais ça sera ça sera long mais
c'est pas grave
au delà des entreprises de communication
vous sentez aujourd'hui qu'ils aient un
regard qui change qui évolue oui je
pense que le gouvernement commence à
comprendre qu' il faut il faut faire
quelque chose sur ce permis de conduire
inimités que c'est un sujet un dossier
qui revient régulièrement à chaque
gramme
voilà il ya un shack free d'hiver on en
parle et on sait que ça aurait pu être
évité
donc ça voilà je pense aussi que le
gouvernement est très frileux en tout
cas l'été au départ de s'attaquer sur un
sujet aussi délicat puisque on sait que
la voiture en france a laissé sacré
c'est un sujet sacré ils ont été plus ou
moins traumatisés par les le tollé entre
guillemets des 80 km/heure donc c'est
des sujets délicats pour eux à aborder
et en plus avec la crise du coc vide qui
voilà qui évidemment ne donne pas le
moral à toutes les troupes c'est on ne
veut pas être dans un rôle d' imposer
encore plus de mesures mais nous en en
abat en aval ça nous donne le temps de
préparer ce dossier là justement de
travailler sur des solutions
alternatives de mobilité qui sont
vraiment le plus gros chantier de ce
projet donc donc on continue est
vraiment moi j'ai le soutien du
gouvernement je peux le dire aujourd'hui
et je sais qu'ils continueront à
travailler avec moi le temps qui fort et
on vous souhaite beaucoup de réussite
dans tous ses projets pour l'une des
roulettes merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé
ce moment avec nous merci pour votre
témoignage
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez retrouver cette interview sur
notre site internet
rt france point tv à plus tard
[Musique]